yeah thank you Leah so joining me to
help us understand the latest
developments is our defense and security
analyst Professor Michael Clarke hello
Michael now first off looking at Kiev we
know that there was a small push
Yesterday by the Russian forces but
really nothing significant very
different here in the South though uh in
Mario poll uh if we have a look at the
close-up map now of the city
um could you please explain to us
exactly what's been happening there yes
the ukrainians had three main forces
trying to defend Mallet polls so they
have the azov Brigade who were looking
after the East they had the Marines in
the North and then the 56th mechanized
infantry in the west and the Northwest
and these two brigades the Azo Brigade
and the Marines have obviously had their
perimeters penetrated so have the 56
mechanized to a degree but they seem to
be still fighting part of the of the
battle within the city center uh any
relieving forces are more than 6 miles
away for the Ukrainian so it's probably
getting towards the end of the process
now now as we know has
a bombardments and again civilian Target
this time
goal
yes and because fighting is going on in
exactly those parts of the city nobody
can get to them so as with the the
theater there may be X number of people
trapped in the rubble still alive nobody
can get to them it's pretty bad uh also
important to talk about these
unconfirmed reports that civilians in
the city have been scooped up and taken
away by the Russians two Russian cities
yes the rosgradia who are the internal
troops who came in with the uh The
Invasion forces and their job is to
round people up and keep civil order and
British and American intelligence have
said and they've been right about
everything else that the Russians have
drawn up lists of people that they
wanted to take away so if this is true
maybe this is the beginning of that sort
of process now if we move over to
version we know that this was the place
that the Russians took first of any
significance
um we've seen Defiance there and
actually we have some video Don't We
that shows us that continues yes I mean
this is a sky video and it confirms
really what we've known for each day
that the citizens of Persian are getting
out and about and they're just
confronting Russian troops they're
confronting their tanks and their guns
in a passive demonstration of of
patriotism they're showing Flags they're
they're even Flags you can see in the
video on the roofs of some of the
buildings there's not much the Russians
can do about that and it's pretty clear
that although the Russians occupy
kersian they really don't control it now
if we look to the north we get our next
map up you can see that we've heard from
the president's office president Celeste
zielinski's office that there is concern
about an attack from Le Belarus into
that vollin region who would those
Invaders be yeah well it makes perfect
military sense for the Russians to try
and open up another front to give the
Ukrainian something else to worry about
to the rear if that takes place it will
almost certainly be Belarusian troops if
president lukashenko of Belarus has
decided to join the war then he is
putting himself alongside President
Putin in the dock of world opinion and
he'll probably then suffer the same fate
eventually okay Michael Clarke thank you
for joining us